seek it to you make it baby that's what
I have done that what I do
save your munitions Carol
our friends have arrived
[Music]
hey everybody this is gonna be my
Walking Dead episode 2 video probably
the biggest surprise of the episode was
that season one character returning that
we'll talk about in a second but there's
a new round of that ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so in the grand tradition of Walking
Dead they cut the episode intro in a
really weird way so you know you're
jumping around in time you just don't
know how far forward thankfully they
weren't doing that thing where they redo
an episode from someone else's
perspective they've done that a couple
times in the past but for the most part
this episode was set completely after
the events of episode 1
it was just a divide-and-conquer
situation they're going after guns
they're going after supplies everything
that they need smash and grab but top 10
WTF and easter eggs so the first group
Aaron just goes and starts flanking the
largest group of Savior's mostly to keep
them busy I think it's just bonus points
if they're able to take a bunch of them
down which they do in the ones Savior
that start shaming the squire with the
gun it's a pretty cool death but for the
most part this was the least interesting
storyline in this week's episode so you
have Ezekiel and Carol's group you have
Morgan who's sort of up on his own and
then you have Rick and Daryl's group so
those were really where all the action
was
but number 9 the Walker mode the
satellite station maybe was Eugene that
gave them the idea to do that because
the last time they were at the satellite
station they didn't have all those
defenses but the whole idea with that is
that this is the way the Savior's
control communications it gives them the
ability to dominate a much larger area
because they can coordinate with
different cells in different areas of
the region so usually when you learn
about invasions or you learn about
government takeovers in real life
usually what happens is is the invading
force will take over the communications
of the area so they can prevent the
other side from coordinating it
defensive but really this is sort of the
beginning of Tara and Jesus's conflict
it's all about mercy remember that line
from episode 1 my mercy prevails over my
wrath so they didn't sort of continue
that with Rick's character there were a
couple moments that tested his mercy but
now they're sort of bringing that theme
to the rest of the group and Jesus saves
you can make all the jokes about that
you want Tara is out for blood they
really really wanted you to hate that
Dean guy
holds Jesus at gunpoint after he spends
all that time arguing with Tara about
not killing him and then stomps on
Maggie's prenatal vitamins so they just
want to make Tara seem even more saintly
when she doesn't kill them depending on
whether or not you think she'll snap and
start killing a whole bunch of people
like Morgan did but number eight you
have Carolyn Ezekiel's group that's
moving in for more supplies at this
facility here Carol did a whole lot
without actually seeming like she did a
lot in this episode it felt more like a
zekiel storyline like he's trying to win
her over like look this is how you be a
good leader you have to fake it till you
make it that was probably one of the
best lines from the episode any time he
breaks that Keane character that he
plays like the way he presents himself
the way he talks that crazy speechifying
that he does that's all an act when he
breaks and says you gotta fake it till
you make it that's the real Ezekiel so
it'll be interesting to see if the show
tries to develop a relationship between
the two of them and in private you get
to see more of the real Ezekiel because
in the comics he was actually with
Michonne but on the TV show Michonne is
with Rick so it's just a little bit
different but number 7 Rick and Daryl's
group are looking for more guns they
find a building they start finding their
way up to the top Daryl has a bit of a
flashback to when he was at the mercy of
Dwight like they had that moment during
episode one where they shared that look
like Daryl still kind of wants to kill
him but understands that they need
Dwight and Rick even tells Daryl during
the episode so far his information has
been good and for the most part they've
been accurate to comic book Dwight so I
don't think there's anything suspicious
going on with his character it's really
the fighting within the group like you
have the Terra Jesus stuff that's going
on that's where the real conflict is
going to start to develop because now
that there are sort of this unit this
movie against the Savior's the whole
idea is mercy they keep hammering that
home but number six the big Morgan twist
I totally loved when he got up like he
was coming back to life like he's this
inhuman killing machine now the creepy
music that they gave him as he was
waking up made it feel more like a
Terminator movie so because Shane is a
Walking Dead character and Jon Bernthal
is on Punisher now there's all kinds of
Punisher jokes flying around but he felt
more like The Terminator like this
unfeeling machine that would continue
until his task was done and he straight
up starts hallucinating Rick from last
season where he was talking about not
leaving any of them alive just hardcore
preaching in the church got to take them
all down but sort of a stray moment
number 5 the WTF looking melty Walker
what happened to this we don't have time
for it and they just blow right past it
the thing about this to remember is it
feels like it'll come back at a later
date like it'll be some weapon some
virus some disease that they'll be able
to use to their advantage or we'll be
able to hurt them so it just feels like
one of those narrative ticking time
bombs that they'll come back to blow up
in their face the way that Morales or
two blew up in Rick's face at the end of
the episode but number four Rick had
that badass brawl with the dude we don't
know what his name was but they
straight-up pound each other and he's an
animal like you've seen him fight when
he's at his limits before like when he
goes all crazy at the end of season five
and Michonne almost has to take him down
the twist though was so great number
three when he walks into the next room
and doesn't find any guns just finds the
baby Gracie there's all sorts of imagery
here but the whole thing about the name
Gracie is the guy that he just killed
had a tattoo that said God is Grace
so I think they wanted to tell you that
Rick just killed her father
so one he's a little remorseful about
that like oh my god I killed this baby
girl's father what would it be like if I
died and baby Judith didn't have a
father he sees himself in the mirror
they were a little on the nose with the
mirror above the baby's bed like he
stares at himself you you kind of see
what's going on here he's questioning
his sanity he's not a psychopath my
mercy prevails over my wrath
this is him sort of figuring that out
like when we have the flash-forward
that's him after all the craziness after
they defeat negan so it's almost like it
takes him all season long to figure that
out and all the other characters for
that matter too so I don't think there's
a world we live in where Rick kills a
baby that hasn't already turned into a
walker like if the baby had been a
walker then maybe he would have put it
out of its misery
but the really WTF thing here is that
they have all the liens painted on the
wall some Lions will eat their young and
then you have Shiva who's a tiger in the
episode who's eating a whole bunch of
people number two though is Terah and
Jesus's conflict so the whole deal
with them at the end of the episode
where she's like yeah Maggie might
listen to you but Rick listens to me
she's got this crazy Rambo bloodlust
she's mad about them killing Deniz and I
think it's a bit of a pivot from a
writing standpoint for the character and
they want to make her seem like she's a
little more hardcore this season so you
guys can let me know in the comments do
you think that she's gonna snap before
the end of the season and kill a whole
bunch of people I don't know that they
want to demonize her that much like they
could take him to the edge like Rick
goes really crazy during season five but
they've already answered the question
several times in the past they'll do it
again this season - they do it every
year
the idea that Rick could be just like
one of these really terrible villain
people if pushed far enough but sort of
in that same vein I totally loved Morgan
hallucinating Rick as he was walking out
into the light at the comm station
almost killing Jarrod like walking right
up and trying to pull the trigger who
has absolutely no idea what's going on
still being a [ __ ] he was the guy
that kept harassing Richard last season
so they really want to make it seem like
it's a struggle that the survivors
aren't going to kill these saviors
there's such big [ __ ] but my mercy
prevails over my wrath it all comes back
to that Rick moment so horse number one
WTF Morales is back the last time we saw
him was in season 1 episode 5 he split
off from Rick's group to go to
Birmingham to try and find more family
we never heard from them again so if you
weren't sure what all those weird sounds
are as they cut to black at the end of
the episode it's the sound of Rick
pulling his gun out of its holster in
the click of the hammer on myrrh Alice's
gun going back as if all he has to do
now is let go in the bullet will fire
like they're totally going at each other
in this moment but don't forget the
daryl is also there with them and Rick
fought that guy off all by himself
meaning that we didn't know what Daryl
was doing for that whole period of time
so he might come rescue him and I
wouldn't be surprised if they pull him
back from the brink because Morales is
not a terrible person and they don't
want to demonize Rick so maybe they'll
try to have him win Morales over and
he'll help them out in some small way
because I think the idea is is that most
of these Savior's don't want to be
saviors they're just there because they
don't have any better option so let me
know in the comments what do you think
is gonna happen to Morales do they kill
him in the opening scene
next week's episode or do you think they
try to win him over what will happen
next is this some new Star Wars footage
drop so I'll do a video for that there's
also some footage of Jeffrey Dean Morgan
talking about being Thomas Wayne Batman
during the flash flashpoint movie so a
whole bunch of comic book stuff coming
up I'll try to get that out as fast as
possible congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner the conservative arrow
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
my episode 1 video and you can click
here for brand new Game of Thrones thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight